as coveted restrictions start to ease  here in nevada many parents  are excited to see youth sports  competitions come back to the state  jennifer gonzalez's son plays club  soccer here in las vegas  they were able to resume practice back  in october but had to travel out of  state for his competitions  under recent orders from the governor  games can resume in our state next month  gonzalez says it's not only great news  for her family  it's good for the whole community that's  part of the challenge with  transitioning in and out of all of these  changes  is the lack of connection not only for  our kids but also for our community and  family members  because that's what youth sports is  about just bringing together the  community  gonzales says it's also been hard for  parents to connect since they can't  really congregate or sit together during  those games  youth sports tournaments are approved to  return to nevada on march 15.